-The President held
yet another rally
where people were packed
close together,
despite
the coronavirus pandemic,
after telling his supporters
that virtually nobody
is affected
by a disease that has killed
at least 200,000 Americans.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
The President has been
traveling the country,
holding big rallies with people
packed closely together,
often without masks,
and putting Americans in danger
in order to make himself
feel better.
And remember,
viruses get passed on,
so he's potentially
exposing people
who aren't even at his rallies
to the spread of coronavirus,
all because the adoration
of his fans soothes his ego.
Just a tip, if you're a cashier
at the Chick-fil-A closest
to the rally venue,
you might consider dressing
like the bad guys from "E.T."
By the way,
this isn't hypothetical.
We already know his rally
in Tulsa
led to a surge in cases there.
At this point, Trump rallies
are on the list
of high-risk activities,
just like doorknob licking,
hugging everyone on the subway,
and eating shrimp
at the strip club buffet.
And I'm not even really sure
what rally attendees
are getting out of it for all
the risks they're taking.
I mean, you can't even
really follow
what the guy is saying.
Most of the time, he just stands
there sweating profusely
and complaining about things
he recently watched on TV.
His rallies are like karaoke
night at the concussion ward.
You could safely get
the same experience
FaceTiming with your uncle
who lives in Boca
and eats dinner every night
at 4:30 at Red Lobster.
[ As Trump ]
You have to get there early
so they don't run out
of the Cheddar Bay Biscuits.
We love -- We love the
Cheddar Bay, don't we, folks?
[ Normal voice ]
For example, Trump often tells
two kinds of fake stories,
stories about going home to
his wife, Melania, after rallies
and stories about generals
and other people who come up
to him and call him "sir."
Obviously, all these stories
are made up.
But even Trump seems
to have trouble
keeping track of his bull[bleep]
because yesterday at his rally
in Pennsylvania,
he mixed them up.
-Last night, now, I went home,
and I tell you this.
I go home all the time.
"First Lady,
how'd you like the crowd?"
"Sir, I didn't see it.
I didn't see it.
But I didn't see it, Donald.
I didn't see it."
Sometimes she'll call me
Mr. President,
but she's only kidding,
believe me.
-Your wife calls you, sir?
Are you married to Marcie?
And if so, Marcie,
what are you doing?
Stop pretending to be something
we all know you're not.
While I can enjoy Trump
forgetting he was telling
a fake Melania story and
slipping into a "sir" story,
I do wish it was
the other way around.
Chances are most people
at a Trump rally
think a wife should call
her husband "sir,"
but none of them would be okay
if a general called you
"darling."
[ As Trump ] This general came
up to me, big guy, tough guy,
hands like frying pans,
and he took me by the shoulders
and said, "Darling,
you were great tonight."
And then give me
the tiniest kiss.
Tiniest kiss on the lips,
a pair of butterfly wings.
Why is blood coming out
of everyone's ears?
[ Normal voice ]
The truth is, Melania
doesn't call you anything.
Not "sir," not "Mr. President."
Maybe "you again."
I doubt they've spoken at all
during the last four years,
except for maybe that one time
they were leaving
the White House
and he pointed at a puddle.
Doesn't do anything for her,
just points at the puddle.
Did your marriage
counselor recommend
finding things you both
have in common?
[ As Trump ] Oh, look water.
Melania like water.
I've seen her drink water.
You know what?
I'll point at it.
Point at it
so she doesn't miss it.
You know, it's hard to believe,
just yesterday
that was Frosty the Snowman,
tragic loss.
Tragic loss of Frosty.
But it is
my constitutional right
to appoint a replacement
for Frosty.
And I'm happy to announce
that our newest addition
to beloved Christmas mascots
is [bleep] bird, the penguin.
[ Normal voice ]
That's the first time I'm
putting eyes on [bleep] bird,
and I feel like
the graphics department
did a really nice job.
So Trump says that
his wife calls him "sir."
But sure, Joe Biden is the one
in cognitive decline.
I've never heard Biden
make a mistake like that.
And the one time he did mix up
his wife and his sister,
he immediately
corrected himself.
-By the way, this is my
little sister, Valerie,
and I'm Jill's husband.
Oh, no, this is Val.
Val, you switched on me.
This is my wife.
This is my sister.
They switched on me.
-I mean, sure, it would be ideal
if it hadn't happened at all,
but if that had been Trump,
he would have insisted
he was right.
[ As Trump ]
Why are you laughing?
This is my wife, Melania.
[ As Pence ]
Sir, I am the vice president.
[ As Trump ]
Come here, Melania.
Let me give you a kiss.
Oh, Melania's icy tonight.
[ Normal voice ]
And the Melania story mix-up
was still probably
the most coherent thing he said.
A weird dynamic has developed
with Trump
where he routinely says
some of the most depraved,
authoritarian things
a president has ever uttered.
And as a nation, we mostly just
let him pass by without comment.
We treat him like a guy handing
out leaflets on the subway.
I wouldn't be surprised
if at the first debate,
Joe Biden just put in earbuds
and started playing "Minecraft"
on his phone.
For example, on Monday
at another -- excuse me --
one of his coronavirus
cough-athons in Ohio.
Trump told his supporters
that virtually nobody
is affected by the coronavirus
as the total number of deaths
in the U.S. hit 200,000.
-It affects elderly people,
elderly people with heart
problems and other problems.
If they have other problems,
that's what it really affects.
That's it.
You know, in some states,
thousands of people,
nobody young.
Below the age of 18,
like nobody.
They have a strong
immune system.
Who knows? You look --
You take your hat off
to the young
because they have a hell
of an immune system,
but it affects virtually nobody.
It's an amazing thing.
-Imagine standing there
and listening to the president
tell you who dies from a virus
and having it describe you
to a T.
[ As Trump ]
It affects old people.
Old people with heart issues,
maybe diabetes, you know,
people who gather together
in large groups without a mask.
They're certainly in
the danger zone.
[ Normal voice ]
Must be such a weird drive home.
"Hey, honey, you think
my pacemaker
counts as a heart issue?"
But, yeah, man,
it's an amazing thing
that nobody's really affected
by this deadly
and highly contagious virus.
I'm sure all those people died
just to make you look bad.
I heard they were deep state
Antifa terrorists
paid for by George Soros
to stop breathing.
They're probably not even dead.
They're probably all hanging out
on Antifa Island
talking about how much they love
socialism and fake news.
The President is
a deeply sick man.
Usually when you hear
someone talk like that,
they're being fitted
for a Hannibal Lecter mask
or holding a sign
in Times Square.
Coronavirus isn't real.
De Blasio is an alien.
The moon is following me.
Every time I turn around,
it's there.
COVID is currently
the third highest
cause of death in the U.S.
200,000 people have died.
Many more could die
in the coming months.
And the President is out there
telling people six months in
that virtually
nobody's affected.
Just because you're not affected
doesn't mean nobody's affected.
You're safe because
you and everyone around you
get tested every day and you get
the results back instantly.
Meanwhile, regular people
had to wait in their cars
for hours like they were
lined up at a toll booth
trying to leave New Jersey
during the third quarter
of a Jets game or Giants game.
They're both bad at football.
I say that risking the fact
that the Giants are the team
all the security guards like.
Also, one more thing,
it's not true
the coronavirus only affects
the elderly
and people
with pre-existing conditions.
But even if it were,
that's like half the population.
It's like if an ax murderer
was on the loose
and the cops were like,
"Don't worry.
It only affects
sexy teens taking showers."
And Trump knows better.
He knows better.
Remember, he told journalist
Bob Woodward
in those taped conversations
that the coronavirus is actually
very infectious and very deadly
and didn't just affect
the elderly.
In fact, he went out of his way
to say young people
could get sick, too.
It's amazing how different
he sounds in private
when he wants to impress someone
he thinks is important.
It's like seeing Larry the
Cable Guy in a fancy restaurant
wearing sleeves and
holding forth on wine varietals.
Trump almost sounds normal.
It's like a local news story
where a guy gets hit on the head
with a paint can
and becomes a genius,
except Trump probably got hit
in the head with a golf ball
after shanking it in the woods
and ricocheting it off a tree.
[ As Trump ]
Coronavirus is a hoax.
On the other hand,
I did read a double-blind,
peer-reviewed clinical study
that suggests aerosols
are a more concerning vector
than fomites.
Did I say fomites?
I meant...
-Yosemites.
-Remember?
We forget,
but that also happened.
Hearing Trump
on the Woodward tapes
is like seeing
the original Homer Simpson.
It's a completely
different person.
That's Homer?
I thought that was
Walter Matthau.
[ Laughs ]
Sal Gentile writes some
trenchant political commentary,
but he also got that old
Homer joke in.
So we know that Trump is at
least capable of understanding
the deadly reality of the virus,
which makes his lies about it
all the more psychotic
and criminally negligent.
He knows people will die,
and he's telling them
not to worry anyway.
He's President Big Tobacco.
Anyone else doing that
would get sued or go to jail.
If an auto manufacturer
told people their car
was perfectly safe
even though they knew
there were no airbags
and the brakes were 50/50,
they'd get in trouble.
Of course, if they just
called it a Maga-rati,
40% of the country
would rush to buy it
so they could own the libs
by driving off Freedom Cliff.
The simple fact is
that sane people
who've spend any amount of time
with him
know Trump is a deeply
disturbed individual
with no regard for human life,
who doesn't care about anyone
or anything
unless it can enrich
or empower him.
We keep hearing that same story
over and over
from people who worked for him,
quit, and called him
unfit for office after leaving.
Every three days,
there's another book
by a former
administration official,
and not one of them
has been titled
"He Was Very Nice
& That Was Fine."
I mean, think about
how many people have left
Trump's inner circle
or his administration
and basically said
he's a sociopath
who's incapable
of doing the job.
It can't be a coincidence that
all these people worked with him
and now hate his guts.
Like, if you were a manager
at Best Buy
and 50 --
50 of your employees quit
and they all said it's
'cause the new guy, Brad,
kept putting pictures
of his butthole
up on the 4K ultra HD TVs,
your reaction wouldn't be like,
"Well, I guess they're leaving
'cause they're Walmart fans."
Take, for example, Olivia Troye,
former adviser
to Vice President Mike Pence,
who worked on
the coronavirus task force.
In a recent ad for Biden,
Troye explained that she quit
because Trump didn't care
if people died from the virus,
including -- including
his own supporters.
-The truth is,
he doesn't actually care
about anyone else but himself.
He made a statement once.
It was very striking.
I never forgot it because it
pretty much defined who he was.
When we were
in a task force meeting,
President said, "Maybe this
COVID thing is a good thing.
I don't like shaking hands
with people.
I don't have to shake hands
with these disgusting people."
Those disgusting people
are the same people
that he claims to care about.
These are the people
still going to his rallies today
who have complete faith
in who he is.
-I'm surprised Trump ever shook
hands with his supporters.
He's a wealthy germophobe
who lived in a golden penthouse
and traveled everywhere by limo.
Of course he was disgusted
by interacting with normal,
non-rich people.
Even before the pandemic,
he probably finished his rallies
and then sent Mike Pence out to
shake hands in a Trump disguise.
[ As Pence ] I really don't want
to do this, sir.
[ As Trump ] Then maybe you
shouldn't have been so stingy
with your kisses.
Maybe you're starting
to regret that choice now.
[ Normal voice ] Republicans
are in lockstep behind this guy,
all so they can win
and maintain power.
That's the corrupt bargain
they've made --
back an unrepentant
criminal sociopath
who's overseen
the preventable deaths
of hundreds of thousands
of Americans.
And in return, they get
a conservative super majority
on the Supreme Court that could
destroy Obamacare,
rip up Roe v. Wade,
and invalidate the results
of the November election
if Trump loses.
That's their plan.
They do not care
about the pandemic.
Inside the Trump White House
and the Republican Party,
the COVID death toll...
-Affects virtually nobody.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over two million
meals a year to men,
women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.